tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa vj e dolcissimo su
paranormal anche un videogame in viola
ora riuscito un casino di tempo fa tipo
due anni fa al papello anni fa non è un
caso di tempo fa ma chi se ne frega
permesso di mettere ghazi un videogioco
horror le cui ci sono delle cose
paranormali non chiedete vito aveva chi
se ne fotte perché mi avete consigliato
voi quindi andiamo così chi se ne frega
bella zio sono bravi come stai
ok sapendo bassi sia cazzo sì mi ricordo
quella volta in champ beccati al
ristorante che tutti lato nota è stata
praticamente dovrebbe aver detto le
cagate solite le tipo angie notte riesco
a dormire perché si muovono i quadri da
soli quindi va bene se l'ex memphis
batte lo manca ho mancato il mouse
stavolta l'ho presa se grande inter di
hunting 32 sì ma stai calmo cazzo perché
ci siamo partiti chi che cos'è sono
stato una donna col teletrasporto di
goku è una cosa assurda è tanto l'ictus
è sta roba è una e un nano è pronto come
cazzo ti permette di andare in giro per
casa mia come se fosse casa tua e sta
proprietà privata tornate lo vedi cosa
hai fatto sei un cazzo di guastafeste
ragazzi ma allora qua mi entrano le
scatole in casa e mi mettono io ti
denuncio ci hai capito mi hai appena di
struttura statue toolani fargli ragazzi
quale scatto le credono di fare come
cazzo vogliono ma non hanno capito un
piano a che fare io ve lo dico c'è un
computer ios e ci sono le notifiche di
facebook allora per fermo libro antola
che devo controllare non tipiche sono
tutti i nani qui addio in cucina che
devo trovare se c'è la nutella se non
c'è pazienza facciamoci un toast in
qualcosa perché c'è fame c'è il caffè
perfetto il caffè volete caffè
nessuno è perfetto faccio io
sta andando a [ __ ] la teiera dove la
teiera termica eccola a sentirlo filo
capitola rumore ok perfetto che vi si è
svolto a tommaso vista aspettate un
attimo lega che mi si è smontato tipo
tranquilli è tutto a posto
se solo contatto perfetto e sono cose
che succedono in casa regala quando
quando mettete a posto le teiere può
capitare che la casa di 20 rossa o che
si spenga il gioco ok ragazzi si sono di
nuovi si è chiuso il gioco non tiri temi
perché ci sono questi cazzo di rumori
dov'è la nutella nel frigo a vista roba
che sta pisciando nella mia casa mia
fermo fermo che la teiera aperti spiega
aperto il rubinetto portato di nuovo
[ __ ]
ma chi è quel monache sbatte la porta in
soffitta sinistra anzi si è aperto anche
il frigo vediamo se c'erano tele
effettivamente non c'era fini non e non
è servito a un cazzo tutto sto casino
sì ma la vado a comprare se la vuoi
ragazzi le donne che si incazzano perché
non c'erano della nel frigo
esiste il cazzo di campanello non so se
qualcuno te l'ha spiegato comunque a
gaza a buongiorno lei non aveva neanche
vista ma forse è meglio che non la
vedevo allora c'è qualcuno che ha
tentato di entrare ho sentito qualcuno
eccessivamente bussare non so se è un
caso no infatti mi sa che questo rumor e
ancora ho detto che devi stare devi
stare nonna e sento un cellulare che
squilla deve essere tipo ecco i fatti
c'è una a un iphone che squilla
bellissima ai quattro formaggi e
cresciuto grazie devono essere il tizio
di prima che bussava in una mano mio
trovati in casa quindi ma chiamato
avevamo ordinato delle pizze scusate
ragazzi non ve l'avevo detto volevo fare
in amore ok mi sa che è arrivato di
nuovo ragazzi e c'è ma c'è il pizzaiolo
che tenta di entrare senti togliti dai
[ __ ] perché c'è qualcuno che deve
entrare
anzi anzi novelli meglio se stai di
cos'è ma non entra nessuno ragazzi lui è
il mio bodyguard ve lo presento si
chiama gigio è stata avanti alle porte
evita che qualcuno entri e chi se ne
fotte comunque che cazzo guardi tu è
bello bello e pamela la pioggia vero
guarda shark e compiuta suoi spi petardi
puoi farlo è la cosa ha sempre questo no
che figo chissà cosa
nella figata parcheggio di noci madonna
ma questo non è un giardino siamo in
amazzonia la carica ma che cazzo ok riva
e l'immondizia buttavo lo stesso e senza
che tu di che che la sta piovendo
perfetto sono ragazzi e qualcuno già un
ombrello perché poi brutto pezzo di
merda questa è casa mia come ti permetti
che ma chiuso dentro bastardo di meno ma
chiuso fuori non dentro borse relation
la tua videocamera si spegnerà presto
trova un letto ma mi hanno chiuso fuori
che cazzo trovo le e basta io questo a
vela segno segnatevi la faccia di sto
[ __ ] ragazzi e poi li tira un
cazzotto di quelli che se li ricorda per
tutta la vita ora se mi deve lasciare
fuori che piove pure sto stronzo aprite
a questa porta a porta a no era era
aperta e rape lurido stronzo di merda
che pianifica un calcio attivato
affaccio strike tu e tutti gli altri
devo devo salire sti cazzo di barili che
si muova allora dovete stare fermi
barili devono stare devo buttarci
l'immondizia lì dentro e nei soli
soffitta sentite che c'è a perfetto
posto contro non pensavo di piuttosto
abile in soffitta effettivamente lei non
ce ne sono i kings incredibile questo va
bene in soffitta non c'è niente io
pensavo di sì comunque che che è
successo
ragazzi ho visto qualcuno che stava qui
non so chi era non ne ho idea era era
qui l'ho visto
aiuto aprite togliti dai [ __ ] qua di
garda dei miei stivali tagli ragazzi che
cazzo successo aiuto aiuto pizzaiolo
chiama qualcuno mi porti da quattro
formaggi al mento rumore che se a
qualcuno di sopra ma io ci possa ma ci
posso andare di sopra lega che cazzo
adesso non mi sta piacendo aiuta lo
studio studio studio se non so non c'è
lo studio la videocamera si è rotta
tanto c'è michael jackson sul muro
fantastico
facciamo finta che non ci sia michael
jackson buongiorno sentite io ci aveva
una videocamera una volta mi è sparita
c'è una chiave una chiave che non posso
pre il primo videogioco horror nel quale
non posso non si possono prendere le
chiavi fantastico ogni punto accesso
scarica strozzo dai giochi giu dello
sporco bianchi nei movimenti facciamo
finta di niente nello scarico lo scalco
non è sicuro o intasato un po il senso
ragazzi se volete scappare di casa non
mettetevi nel cesso perché succede
questo
comunque io io pensavo di sic kart
successo spiega che cazzo successo
regala non era così prima che non
capitola facciamo così chiamiamo allora
di pizzaiolo l'idraulico e tu che cazzo
ci fai qui ci gioco adatto di vistare di
sotto a bloccare la porta ok non servi
al cazzo qui devi allora facciamo così
io ti chiudo la porta in faccia al mio
treno voglio vederti più 123
[Musica]
ciò ci gioco usagi sono verso la porta
si è chiusa non pensavo di peccati in
faccia chiamate un'ambulanza ragazzi mi
serve unità jolo un idraulico è
un'ambulanza per ciccio perché è rimasto
a terra poverino gli ho tirato una
portata in faccia e non pensavo
effettivamente di falli malnome ok e la
vela e la vendetta dei gg
cos'è successo e ragazzi state calcolo
se una gang bang sentite io vado a di
sopra che merda [ __ ] perché è
caduto uno gigio che cazzo e che cosa
sto scura allora spiegami che cazzo stai
famiglia sta bene e ti sta solo bene
l'avevo detto che avrei fatto strike
ragazzi strada sono caduti tutti
perfetto strike di gigi fuorchè ago
premere per per dormire ricaricare la
video k che dormendo si ricarica la
videocamera è giustissimo ragazzi
se andate a dormire domani vi trovate
due toscani prospettate vero di jobs
gigio che cazzo fai ragazzi gizio si sta
alzando e non a chi non ha buone
intenzioni che magari organizza un rave
party mentre non ci sono dato ragazzi
dormo mai sempre notte non si sa perché
il giorno non esiste ma non importa
perfetto di giochi 6 davis te alla tua
io la corrente la pago la devi smettere
di farlo allora la finisci la finisci
inutile che telecomando te lo sei
nascosto nel culo perché tanto te lo
trovo tutto stop che voi ragazzi è
peggio di michael jackson sto tizio mi
sa fare le cose michael hai trovato un
degno erede
quante cazzo di volte ti ho detto di non
usare i petardi in casa bianca se milano
retta una volta mio dio sembra una casa
prefetto mettiamo realtime finalmente
che era ora di vedere un po di potere
perché c'era miley cyrus sta diventando
una roba tipo tipo the ring è una cosa
orribile non ho questo è un porno a
prefetto ragazzi stiamo andando sul
piccante che abbiamo anche un tecnico
della televisione già che ci siamo tanto
dobbiamo chiamare mezzo mondo il cazzo
mi invii turi la porta di casa ma chi te
l'ha chiesto quindi di paghi tutto tutto
i petardi tut
ragazzi io lo faccio lavorare lo faccio
sgobbare come uno schiavo ve lo dico
ragazzi non so perché cazzo se un
piccioni soffitta dagli echi che come
hai fatto entrare mi hai preso per un
nido ma perché io non do wah piccione di
merda chi cazzo ti ha fatto entrare essi
su che cos'è rimessi cassato tutto
brutto dov'era dove era sparito devo
andare allora facciamo così anni sopra
se non pro sesto rumore che sento ogni
tanto non lo so e bruti che cazzo kacar
che kimi ha fissato sulla moquette
resta un dubbio che mi servì
perseguiterà per la vita pre sei tu
sergio di camerano fa ciò che cazzo
estero non si capisce niente
sono morto cosa succede che vedo tutto
capovolto
ma voi ragazzo non sono svenuto non lo
so perché lo rimette troppi attacchi
paula normali ma non importa ragazzi da
dolci sono private visto gioco è fatto
di eventi paranormali quindi ce ne sono
tantissimi altri ma devi sapere se
volete io li faccio nel frattempo che
sono svenuto qualche modo riesco a
rinvenire in qualche modo non lo so come
al solito ragazzi 6 video è piaciuta
assai documento mi piace ai carpigiani
facebook e come ogni video trovate nella
descrizione a sera il senatore city
scrive de neri ci vediamo al prossimo vi
do belle ragazze